did you watch the fights on Saturday I
watched the fights on Saturday why
didn't I like the fights went on for 20
hours because they did I was glad I was
glad that rose namajunas won that fight
I think she's awesome I was glad that I
disagreed with the max Holloway decision
I think max won that fight a hand it not
handedly but fair and square I think it
was three to two yes no no question and
it was because max it was really
interesting because max was pressing the
pace and he he was moving forward if the
last fight he was always moving back
because valosky kept moving forward and
that changed in this fight that was
weird but listen man it is what it is it
is what it is I was very surprised that
Maxwell Smith Mazda well I mean I don't
know how I thought this III think that
Maz Badawi said this because he had I
was talking about this he had to suck
from 194 to 70 in a very short period of
time so I knew his wind would be a
problem or that's why I was worried
about and I knew it would be
lucemon never has a wind problem I don't
know where he gets that cardio from and
he's a [ __ ] grinder you know he just
how are you gonna solve that problem
it's that Jon Fitch copy it's even more
than that don't be because it's like
yeah striking you'll worry about - yeah
you do it yes and it's like this
incredible pace and it's like you know
we seem to be getting a little tired
we've never seen newsmen get tired
evening it's Kobe Cummington and Woodley
no Edward so it's like and he's also
very smart keep in mind he's strategic
like he he does weird [ __ ] to win and I
don't know how you solve that problem I
think the only guy who can give him
Fritz is maybe a Leon Edwards could
you'd pose some problems for him even
though he did beat him but he's a better
fighter now but the other thing is I'm
probably the only guy no the only guy I
think that could
finish tomorrow Guzman would be Mazel
all on a full camp
do you remember I don't care what
anybody says and I don't know what mozz
well said his post-fight but a six day
notice is a six [ __ ] day we travel
with travel and everything yeah babble
Kovac test your you say you've been
getting ready but unless you have a
contract on paper and you know who
you're fighting weeks out you're not in
the same grinding mode so and he even
said you know I think he mentally got
tired and third round after that you
knows tops especially with loose men
style so you know if you get Mozilla a
full camp he's really the only guy can
see giving Guzman any trouble anytime
soon Leon adversity could pose some
problems but outside that man I don't
know I I still even even even must has a
full camping his wind is amazing I
spilled on the hay salt that prop once
he closes distance and grabs onto your
knee with that little snatching single
or just clinches up with you and get you
on the ground
you're still hey you're still in the
same [ __ ] body so go still had the
same problem they know this Mazal all
and I think you know people don't
realize this how good is take down the
fence was come on amazing amazing stood
up every time he's a [ __ ] killer he's
a killer
but you might see the same fight you
might see a grind out again most like
come on was also he does throw he throws
well he's a beast but he but he even
admitted what you know when he throw
he's getting tagged he was losing
now all I'm saying is Moz it all has the
cardia to go twenty five minutes
those exchanges a third fourth and fifth
round even the first and second you mean
more willing to do it cuz he doesn't
have to reserve his tank so if he can
trade goes in third fourth and fifth
while those who might get a little tired
you have more of a shot to finish them
cuz that last fight you may really have
a shot in the fourth and fifth it was
just yeah but that's a hundred percent
right that's on percent right Aldo and I
love although and it's exactly what I
figured because of all the mileage and
although you're just not four
whatever reason with fighting when you
take the kind of just just a wear and
tear that although has you're not going
to be able to in the fourth and fifth
rounds you're just not going to keep up
with a younger fresher up-and-coming yan
who is 27 years old it's just different
and and and I could see it
the guy on round 4 was jumping up and
down and ready to [ __ ] know and and
and that's what it's really interesting
with fighting and whatever happens to
your body I'll do look amazing so
muscular so [ __ ] great keep his
[ __ ] great for those three rounds but
at the end of the day man I don't know
it's how long all those been doing it
dude yeah he's so in his striking his
ability to stand right there and and and
move his head and catching angles and
and come back it's just astonishing
he does so hard to get Jana 27 he's
never been in real high-profile fight
fight you're a Faber [ __ ] Jimmy Rivera
they don't have a crazy resume he went
oh you're good at striking I'm not gonna
go here's a line in the sand here's a
Russian line in the sand a Russia moving
back moving so if you want to play this
fisticuffs in a phone booth I'm game for
that and I was like oh [ __ ] he's the
real deal he's he's [ __ ] the real
deal I don't know who beats yan right
now I mean I don't know who beats yan
I'd like to see you know I want to see
him fight what I want to see him fight
cutting your breath Peter including our
breath and [ __ ] fight it's a
[ __ ] fight because coke coke
could he's young and he's too and he's
looking what's that oh he's a good
fighter yes it's hard and he's gonna
stand there too so now no no you realize
you and just on drugs have the same
haircut yeah we had the same haircut we
had the same haircut she's got an
amazing jawline and she's an amazing
fighter but yes we do yes we do she is a
she's a she's a handsome strong I say
this with respect she's a she's got a
strong presence kind of you know the
powerful
all flights Wednesday and Saturday this
week - yes and I'm very excited about
the cater uh in your fight yet you see
that min-hee a [ __ ] a 28th but Barbosa
it was incredible oh you got stronger
eyes the fight went on those woo lions
dude those [ __ ] Hawaiian [ __ ] he's
amazing
[ __ ] he's great and but caterer is uh I
mean Kate a member cater [ __ ] gay
comes a beat the watch for holdup if
that fight was a main event for five
rounds he would have beat the beat I
mean I agree with you cater is a
[ __ ]
well my caterer is as good as anybody in
the 45 his one two is me the straight
one two is its its second to only Conor
McGregor as far as efficiency
there's nobody yeah he's gonna be he's
he's a nightmare for anybody he's a
night dopey he's a guy who could easily
have oh yeah there's no question excited
that I have fights watch Wednesday and
something you on Saturday that's my life
who's fighting Saturday Joey Benavides
yes you'd missed it because I was
talking [ __ ] to you you missed my
favorite fighter now he's my new
favorite fight I have a crush on I'm
wicked smart as well you missed the URI
fight in the özdemir you know over dude
he was pretty small I did see it he's
merciful heart I talking about are you
talking about mr. Kong foo I'm talking
about
are you talking about this showman the
showman
bodied up a hottie top first team all
show pony dude first team
he's a show and I was like I don't know
what he's doing right now he's talking
doing weird [ __ ] he's looking he'd stop
and look over in this direction and then
move back and I was like I get knocked
out yes
hands down yeah it was hard the whole
time well I understand what I understand
that's your prerogative fighter I'm a
hard fight hard fighter
okay I got a little scared use a Siena
now here's my card
here's my
question now doing you wrong oohs
murmurs right number seven the world
he's doing the best there is
does he get away with those same tactics
find a guy like oh I don't know glow
vertex era or Gustafson or you know some
of these other killers let me say this
very clearly watch your dude I know
we're not in studio you watch your
[ __ ] mouth and time up my show pony
hurry now listen you're right I'll come
to your house getting your grill and
I'll surf and turf alcove and surf and
turf you right now but you know you
don't have lungs because you have the
coal I don't have lungs that's true and
I'll call on you now listen listen if he
tries that showboat [ __ ] against if he
tries that show [ __ ] again simply
[ __ ] a technician at least Widow
against I'll Tony Smith against against
[ __ ] what's-his-name from Sweden why
am I playing on his name right now Gus
listen Alexander Gustafson Glover
Teixeira he's gonna pay he's gonna pay
he's not ready for those guys small
stocks that get too excited let's not
get too excited that he did a great job
but you can't you can't be doing you
can't be doing that stuff I think the
other centers might have a an issue with
it if he doesn't if he's fights him and
doesn't look at him you're gonna have
prom with the uncle xanthus they're
gonna have some problems I love them my
guess is by the way it might be how he
deals with nerves it might be sometimes
you showboat because you're [ __ ]
nervous and it gets you in a zone yeah
and it [ __ ] gets the other guy's head
some guys don't get in they don't get
some guys though the veterans it doesn't
get into their head do they go that's
cool you know you should go try that
against John Jones or DC let me know how
that works
no no not against guys like they just
they watch you do all the stuff he done
he done body here to think he's beat
King mo Lawal he beat CB Dollaway you
know he beat some tough dudes and it and
then you know this is
offered him a UFC contract a while noxee
be out correct he's got a very hard
most of miss I mean top-five hardest
hitters in the Division II start yeah
he's got team barber called father time
yes yes we do I have a little better I
my hair's actually oh no it's very
handsome in a hat in a cap yes I saw
myself I thought ostomy looks very
handsome I know what he's doing with his
face he's got his beard he's tall and
handsome and then he takes his hat off
and he looks like Friar Tuck
you can't look like rock nightmares so
we got to make a choice to be shave our
head completely it's a problem so I'm
not better here than him I do have
better hair than ya thank you thank you
hims yep so yeah we're what about Rose
namajunas your thoughts on her
performance and where she goes from here
Rose is the best in the world when when
she's mentally into it when she's not or
she's somewhere else it doesn't feel
like fighting it's a nightmare for so
she was still great though she was still
great against Jessica and rise the first
fight she pieced her up even more yeah
she had that check hook amazing checker
got that jab you know um for me it's
always it's it's rose versus roses roses
ready to go she's the best in the world
I think she can be what Wei Li Zheng He
you know even even you know how good
Whaley is I do think grows beats or if
she's on that night so and Wei Lee even
said roses her toughest competition so
you're gonna get that next Wow Wow
the iding Rose is [ __ ] astonishing she
she's my favorite she and Jana and
Jinger got my favorite female fighters
to watch and by the way I shouldn't even
say that I think they're so technically
great I love watching them fight period
I like them I like watching them as
quite as much as almost anybody else
interesting art male or female oh wow
interesting that's the color I just
think tegra I don't know I just think
technically so Cinemax that's that's I
need you take it down which I think you
better watch Rhoads was just on Jocelyn
steep NBC
oh okay well in some ways I kind of
voice because I like me I like the
fluidity of rose oh sure sure sure did
you like the fluidity of max Holloway
Brian I do like his fluid over time give
me a little pass give me a little pass
there yeah it was exciting though I'll
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]